selling third-party products on ibm
cloud the cloud pack for watson ai ops
version 3.2 and the second season of the
do umq podcast all on this episode of
ibm cloud now
what's up y'all my name is ian and i am
back to bring you the latest and
greatest news and announcements from ibm
cloud
to get things rolling with this episode
i'm excited to announce the general
availability of partner center cell your
one-stop shop for onboarding and selling
third-party products on ibm cloud the
new partner center is the perfect way
for you to get your product in front of
developers right in the environment in
which they work every day
you'll be able to unlock doors to more
clients globally accelerate your time to
market get dedicated onboarding help and
transform your business
best of all you'll be able to onboard
your product to the ibm cloud catalog
through just four major steps
register your company in the partner
center customize how your product will
be displayed in the catalog test and
validate that your product is ready for
use and publish your product to the
catalog
to learn more about onboarding and
selling on our cloud platform check out
the link i've got in the description of
this video
next up i'd like to introduce ibm cloud
pack for watson ai ops version 3.2
version 3.2 focuses on addressing
increasing demands and providing a new
ai ops user experience this means
helping you quickly turn your data into
insight and action by bringing together
incident and performance data from
across your applications
our new story and alert dashboard
experience helps you see the bigger
picture and dive deep to resolve issues
saving you time by consolidating
necessary information into one
experience
we're also introducing a real-time
statistical model of log anomalies this
will help you get started faster by
training on and detecting anomalies with
ai in just 30 minutes instead of the
weeks or months that other ai op
solutions typically require
to learn more about these new features
hit the link below
to close things out today i wanted to
let you know that season 2 of the do you
mq podcast is now available on your
favorite podcast platform
host james wood will be joined by senior
ibm mq experts customers and business
partners to share their knowledge and
insights about recent innovations and
how to get the most out of existing
capabilities
the 20 to 30 minute episodes span
technology deep dives and how
capabilities can be used to drive
business value and they're a great
listen for anyone who works with data
so make sure you check out the new
season for episodes on streaming queues
automated workload balancing integrating
multiple messaging styles and ibm mqs
manage cloud service click the link
below to learn more
thanks so much for joining me today for
this episode of ibm cloud now if you're
interested in learning more about the
topics i've covered make sure you
explore the links in the description of
this video and again please don't forget
to subscribe to our channel to stay up
to date on what's going on in the cloud
now
you